all right guys bang bang I've got a Liza
here this is going to be a very very
special episode we are going to sit here
remotely and talk for as long as
possible about Criminal Justice Reform
uh Eliza is intimately familiar with a
lot of these issues for um kind of what
she does on a day-to-day basis and she
is also running for uh an elected DA
office which we'll get into but uh just
thank you so much for uh for sitting
down and doing this great to be here I'm
so glad that we got connected and that
we're having this important conversation
absolutely let's start with your
background kind of walk us through um
you know where you grew up kind of how
you got into uh the criminal justice
system and then what you've been doing
over the last couple years so I'm a born
and raised New Yorker uh grew up in
Manhattan and lived abroad in China when
I was young um my sister's Chinese she's
adopted did and I always had a passion
for helping people you know even from
the time I was very young I I recognized
you know the the privilege that I had
from being white and having a you know a
non-white sister and recognizing the
racism that existed and always speaking
out and fighting for those who um were
less fortunate and who who were often
marginalized and uh I realized when I
was like a teenager that I wanted to be
a public defender it just I had a call
calling I went and interned at the the
public defender office here in Manhattan
and I was like Yep this is it found it
this is what I'm going to do with my
life um and so everything I did from
that point forward was to get that job I
mean it was the reason I went to law
school uh and the only job I applied for
when I graduated I remember an interview
in my final round interview with the
head of my organization he was like well
Eliza it was great to meet you um you
know keep us posted if you get any other
job offers and I was like would that
enhance my application in any way and he
said
well no we just want to we just want to
be kept apprised of if you're thinking
of taking another job and I said okay in
that case you should know there won't be
any other job offers it was like all my
eggs one basket um I tell law students
that I speak to don't do that but I but
I really I just knew that this was what
I wanted to do and I anticipated being a
public defender for life and I started
working um at The Legal Aid Society in
October
2009 and I I mean listen I have loved
being a public defender it's you know
it's a an incredible job and and getting
to fight for for people who are treated
so unfairly is is really incredible but
after over 10 years of of representing
over thousands of people charged with
crimes I realized how rigged our
criminal legal system is and you'll
notice throughout our interview I don't
even call it a criminal justice system
because it's not Justice I mean it's
Justice for some but certainly not for
all and people will say oh our system is
broken but to them I say it's not broken
it's operating exactly as designed as a
rigged system is supposed to and it's
marginalizing the very people it was
designed to marginalize and that's
people of color um lgbtqia folks people
who are just everyday working Americans
and um you know non-citizens victims of
sex crimes sex workers I mean it's just
people who are who are already at a
disadvantage and they're just
marginalized by the system which just
perpetuates this cycle um and I realized
that if we want to change the system we
have to change the da and so I made this
huge decision to run for Manhattan
district attorney awesome so let's start
first with just the design of the system
most people who are listening to this
they've heard somebody somewhere along
the way say like hey there should be
Criminal Justice Reform uh they don't
even necessarily understand the issues
first right it's almost like people jump
to the solution so I want to kind of go
step by step here and just walk through
how the criminal justice system works
and then we'll get into what some of
those issues are and how we can solve
them yeah I think that that's a great
way to do it and I think that some of
these things are really exemplified well
by by stories that I have um from my you
know 11 years as a public defender and
one that sticks out in my mind is a
client of mine who um I'll call John for
the purposes of the story and he was an
assistant manager at a Gres in lower
Manhattan um a grocery store for those
who don't live in New York and he had
worked at the same grocery store for 25
years he'd made his way up to assistant
manager and one night he was closing up
the store um around 11: p.m he bought
two bags of groceries with his employee
discount to bring home to his family and
he walked over to the subway and he got
on the Uptown a train um set his
Groceries on the seats next to him and
prepared for his long ride home at the
125th Street stop two uniformed NYPD
officers got on the train grabbed his
groceries dumped them to the ground and
placed John in handcuffs and proceeded
to take him to jail for the night for
the crime of occupying multiple seats on
a Transit
facility literally taking up two seats
on the subway and I met him the next
night and I got him out of jail but for
over 10 years the the frustration and
heartbreak and anger with the way the
system continues to operate has never
gone away and I've seen cases like this
and people being jailed and bullied for
as little as taking up two seats on the
subway and so when I say that the system
is designed to systematically
disenfranchise so many it's it's why I
say the system is not broken like it's
working as designed and it's it's
operating in such a way that someone
like John would get arrested and yet if
I set my purse down next to me on the
same subway there's no chance I would be
arrested for that crime so so this is
like a really really important an I
think kind of story that starts to
highlight there's tons and tons of
nuance and complexity here and I think
you and I are going to do our best to
kind of highlight a lot of that
complexity um for people who uh do not
understand that story that you just
described what is the police response
right because because I can already hear
people saying okay that that is an
example where there's going to be a
crowd that says uh the letter of the law
is that you can't take up two seats in
the subway and therefore uh the police
are just doing their job then there's
another side that says uh yeah but if
you or I did that we wouldn't be
arrested for it and then there's a whole
bunch of people in between who kind of
just throw their hands up and they're
like I don't understand how this even
happens and so kind of if maybe we start
with like the police officers
perspective there is this a thing where
the police are um targeting somebody is
it a a race thing is it a a poverty
thing or like an income thing like how
do you kind of just wrap your head
around that specific incident and like
why it happens if you're even able to
identify
that it's it's such a hard question
because so many of these things have
really just existed for as long as our
society has existed and you know th
these are all pretty much founded on um
racism on white supremacy on maintaining
the status quo for the wealthy and
privilege and and well-connected and
from its Inception you know our system
was
white male land owners who wanted to
maintain their power and you know we'll
probably get into talking about this
later but you know the the how all of
this kind of stems from from Jim Crow
laws and and what what the ways in which
we systematically disenfranchise people
and so I think that you know are there
police officers who wish they didn't
have to make the arrests of people who
are taking up two seats on the subway
but the system of incentives for police
officers is is is messed up and maybe
but like also it's just such a such a
the the system as a whole operates in
such a way that it really
is propping up and maintaining the
status quo in like a very significant
way yeah when you say police incentive
describe that a little bit because I
think that part of this is um I I almost
think of the criminal justice system has
like kind of stages and so if uh you're
John and that scenario and you're riding
the subway you're just a private citizen
kind of going about your business um the
first stage of kind of going down this
path is like there's an encounter with
the police right and then there's an
arrest and then there's kind of uh bail
and and sentencing and like all that
stuff will come but just talk a little
bit maybe about the police incentive
whether it's that incident or another uh
kind of situation how do you see maybe
the challenges with some of the police
incentives uh and why it may lead to
some of uh the the
examples well I mean the I think there's
some
very very serious and important
conversations that we're having with
regards to the police right now and I
think that you know there's just been so
little um police accountability so
little police um
transparency uh you know you've probably
heard a lot of conversations I mean
there were so many people posting about
50a in New York the repeal of 50 a you
saw all these like big time celebrities
saying repeal 50a which was the
mechanism by which they kept police
misconduct records uh secret they just
maintained this secrecy so even if
someone had committed misconduct um you
know even if there had been massive
settlements paid out because of that
misconduct uh it was extremely difficult
to get access to those records so you
know there just is there re is there a
reason for that or like what would their
argument be as to why that was important
or or why that was passed
well I guess oh gosh I know you always
you want me to make the opposite the
opposite argument um and it's so hard on
something that you know to argue that
the Personnel records of police that
Shield their misconduct records should
be um should remain hidden um well well
I guess the question is is it
specifically misconduct only or is it
just Personnel records total and the
reason why I ask is like um I always go
to like the streem arguments and trying
to understand like is it something where
if a police officer has a health issue
that would also be protected underneath
this no no this is this is the access to
the disciplinary records got it okay so
this is specifically around uh
disciplinary misconduct that those types
of Records this isn't personal
information around your health or or
anything else that might be protected
correct correct and and I think that you
know there were so many Advocates who
who said that you know transparency
about police misconduct conduct is is
like a Panacea for preventing Violence
by police officers um but we we want to
see more significant change as well you
know there there has to be more that we
do um that should really make sure that
um you know I mean the law basically
first existed to prevent defense
attorneys to from going on what they
were calling fishing Expeditions you
know by placing broad subpoenas of
police misconduct records but over time
you know the courts started interpreting
that law as barring any police officer
misconduct records from being disclosed
and that secrecy increased because the
police obviously are are very powerful
and it was one of the one of the worst
laws in the nation with regards to the
Public's ability to access these records
um and you know a majority of states
allowed like way before New York public
disclosure of at least some misconduct
and this is something that that you know
it's like it's so straightforward as to
why this should be public you know
officers are given such enormous power
in their jobs and a history of abusive
Behavior should be available to the
public that they are charged to protect
yep and so with kind of going down this
uh conversation with the police
specifically um you know one of the
things that I've continued to say is
like a lot of the conversation appears
to be uh retroactive or kind of uh the
effect in a cause and effect
relationship um you know I was a uh an
infantry Soldier uh deployed overseas
and I one of the things that just is so
mind open you know or kind of
mindbending to me is myself and many
others that I deployed with have much
more training than the police that walk
our streets every day and there's a
balance between um I don't know
necessarily that's the police officer's
fault right they're looking to get a job
they want to uh you know kind of get
paid do all these things and so they go
through the training that a police
department whether it's in New York City
uh North Carolina where I'm from I think
you can literally become like a a a
sheriff with like six or eight weeks of
training or or some very minimal amount
of training and so it it's almost like
if you look at like yes would the files
being public change Behavior probably
right and it would actually make it much
easier to identify and hold accountable
those who have kind of done the wrong or
or acted in a way that isn't in the best
interest of the population but is the
problem actually like even more in front
of that is it a training problem is it a
a militarization of the police like we
almost create this culture where uh the
police are going to do things that we
don't want them to do and so finding out
about it retroactively is great but like
we should be able to stop that or or
prevent it up front right yeah I think
absolutely that's we want to we want to
prevent it we want want to stop it um we
want to hold accountable people who do
abuse their power um but I think that
you know the data has shown that like
training is not I mean yes there's so
little training that goes on but
training is probably not the answer I
mean if you think about um Minneapolis
being like the quintessential example of
that like where George Floyd was
murdered when a police officer kneeled
on his neck for over eight minutes they
had tried reform um you know five years
ago they were under this pressure in the
wake of of other police killings and
they undertook all these reforms
proposed by the Obama justice department
and procedural reforms and and really
implemented all these trainings on
implicit bias on deescalation on
mindfulness on Crisis
Intervention and even on I think it was
like enhanced early Warning Systems to
identify officers who are problematic
and they brought in in amazing you know
Scholars and initiatives and they spent
millions of dollars on on this to to do
that and all these training programs and
and whatnot and it didn't
work so so and this may be a
misunderstanding on my part um but a
number of people I've talked to my
understanding was that uh a lot of these
programs um and and maybe not so much
the reform programs as much as some of
the accountability type programs have
actually been able to identify
uh certain police officers that are like
higher risk or more likely to do things
that violate the promise to to the
community the problem actually is
enforcing that stuff right so there's
almost like this immunity the um the
police uh unions are able to help people
get back their jobs even after they've
been fired um it almost seems like uh
the
identification whether it's perfect or
you know good uh is definitely Up For
Debate but even if we were able to
identify here in a force of 500 police
officers here's the two bad apples it
almost seems like it's ineffective for
anything that we can do in terms of
being able to basically get them off the
street is that accurate or or do you
have some other understanding of that
well I mean I think that that is
accurate I think that that there's just
so little actual accountability um when
there is misconduct so I think
misconduct stems from I mean there
there's so many different types like
what when we talk about it is it is it
just the you know brutalization and
harassment and and assaults and murders
that we see on the streets it's not just
that it's phys it is the physical
violence in the streets but it's also
the false arrests the falsifying
documents the perjury under oath in the
cour houses and these are all types of
police misconduct that I saw as a public
defender with stunning regularity um
even when raised with the District
Attorney's Office these examples of
chronic miscon conduct on the part of
the police erode our public trust and
harm our communities and I think our
district attorneys have really failed to
and been complicit in the continuing
misconduct perpetrated by our police
departments yeah one of the things that
is is really interesting to me is um
this idea that uh if you look at the
data right so so my understanding of the
data and again you're much more of an
expert on this than I am so correct me
if I'm wrong here but uh somebody I
wrote this big piece earlier this year
about basically uh the police and race
and kind of systematic um you know uh
headwinds uh for certain um soci
economic classes certain demographics
all this stuff and somebody sent me a
thing and they said look the problem is
that everyone talks about the most
extreme case right a George Floyd
situation A bana Taylor and those are
obviously very very bad and and we
should do everything we can to stop them
but the data on I think it's per 1,000
arrest the FBI uh data is like you know
for every 10,000 arrests of a white
person nine people are killed for every
10,00 African-Americans that arrested
eight people are killed and so that data
if you just look at that as a as a a
single piece of data you would say oh we
don't have a racism problem in the
police force in our Criminal Justice
System whatever but what you just
described is it's not just about
physical violence or about um fatal you
know use of fatal Force although there
are issues there it's also just simply
who do we stop who do we arrest who do
we harass who who do we do all these
things and so I think that the hard part
in this is is almost a conversation of
there's data that can be twisted and
used and every party uses it to kind of
tell a different story but then there's
also things that just don't show up in
the data right of of just like why again
does the the example you used of John
why does he get arrested for putting his
groceries in the chair next to him but
if you did the same thing you don't
right does that actually actually show
up in data or not and I think that's
what kind of makes some of this
conversation really hard and also Al you
know quotequote controversial when you
kind of pull it out to a national level
right and and I think that the the data
is quite clear when it comes to um you
know the the over 10 million arrests per
year in in our country um who is being
arrested and what you know what their
race is and and I think that those are
the kinds of things like here in New
York we have a gang database um and the
way in which you get on the gang
database factors as innocent as who you
walk to school with or what color your
shirt is or tattoos you have or social
media posts who you who your friends are
um and there are children as young as 13
on on this database and there's been
like really no public scrutiny of this
and and it's become a huge issue here in
New York but the the unbelievable thing
about it is finally you know we were
able to to get some of the of the data
around it
99% of the people on the on on the gang
database are are black and brown 99% 1%
are white and you know I mean if you're
going to if you're going to tell me that
that that's because oh well only one% no
it's just not true it's simply not true
it just you know we just criminalize
people for the color of their skin and
it's it's just um it's just
completely uh unjust yeah here here's
another perspective that I've heard
people argue and and this one I think to
me is uh much harder to kind of um just
sift through because because I think a
lot of this is interrelated but there's
a number of people who have made the
argument that look uh black brown and
minority people are um much more likely
to be arrested you know targeted Etc uh
by our police forces there's another
group of people that say it's not a race
thing it's a socioeconomic thing it's a
poverty thing right and so again like in
many cases where you know uh if the
police are over patrolling certain areas
that happen to be lower socioeconomic
classes and also have certain
demographics in them you know it's hard
to decipher are they patrolling that
place because it's a poverty thing or
it's a race thing is it both you know
are those two things you know intimately
uh tied together how do you just think
through that relationship between um
kind of socioeconomic status and race
when it comes to policing uh and arrest
and things like that well listen don't
get me wrong uh we have certainly
criminalized poverty in this country um
we've criminalized also you know
substance use disorder and mental health
issues and and we we must change that I
mean there are so many people who end up
sitting in jail charged with a crime you
know we say that we have a presumption
of innocence in this country we say you
are innocent until proven guilty and yet
people sit in jail innocent of any crime
have not been convicted have not plad
guilty but they cannot afford to buy
their freedom and therefore they are
incarcerated while someone who is
charged with something far worse is
charged with something far more serious
uh or is charged with the exact same
thing but has money in their bank
account can pay their way out and not
sit in jail and we know that when you
sit in jail the outcomes are far worse
people end up taking pleas to things
that just to get out of jail um you know
when you're locked up for whether it be
you know 3 months 3 weeks or even just
three days you become exponentially more
likely to reoffend or get rearrested and
it all makes sense right because if
you're locked up even just for a matter
of days and you have a job and you miss
work for three days well you get fired
and then you can't afford to pay your
rent and then you know if you're a
single parent you lose your children to
foster care it's like all of these
things that that that just truly
criminalize poverty um but we also see
the racial disparities and those cannot
be denied you know if you are a person
of color you are much more likely to
have bail set so your poverty does
exacerbate the situation but if you are
you know black or brown and you have a
high you're likely to have a higher bail
set which means you're likely to have a
worse outcome in your case you're more
likely to take a plea you're you're less
likely to take your case to trial
because you know the case drags out and
you've just been sitting incarcerated
for all this time so so I do think that
like to answer your question it is both
things but like they are inextricably
intertwined because of the systemic um
disenfranchisement and systemic racism
that exists in our country okay before
we get into kind of some of the Bale
stuff and that I just want to kind of
finish up the police conversation uh
which
is there's issues right you know and the
way that I uh described it to a friend
and you know I grew up in a family of
five boys uh literally went to war in
Iraq uh there's very few things you're
going to show me uh on the internet that
would shock me but one of the videos
that absolutely shocked me earlier this
year was uh I think it was in Madison
Square Park right right in the corner
there was literally a fist fight between
a private citizen and a police officer
and and there was a uh a mob type
mentality was the police first
protesters uh and I literally saw uh a
cop with a baton just wailing on
somebody and the protester was
absolutely engaged as well right so it
wasn't a the protester was standing
there and kind of not doing anything but
it was a fight and just in in that
environment I think when you just see it
and kind of a 30- second clip you're
like what is happening right in the
middle of Manhattan you have literally
people fighting with the police but then
when you start to understand well wait a
second why are the police there what
were the police doing are the police
actually egging some of this on by the
way are the protesters doing some of the
same things are they agitating the
police right and you start to unpack
some of this what you ultimately decide
is like hey you're not going to off a
30-second video clip understand the
whole situation and so what you've got
to ask yourself is if you zoom out from
one situation like that to kind of the
the holistic picture what is the answer
around police reform is it addressing
police immunity is it you know
addressing some other way like how do
you think about it as the police reform
that everyone's talking about like what
is that
solution um listen I think that first of
all some of these videos that that have
come out in the
last four months mons yeah have have
really um done more to radicalize people
than you know Advocates and activists
and and those of us who've been shouting
about these things for for decades have
been able to do and I think you know the
video that that a lot of people
reference to me when they say and then I
was like oh my God and I had my come to
Jesus moment was the one of the you know
70s something year old man in Rochester
uh just approaching the police and got
pushed over and slams his head yeah and
he's still you know he's still
recovering from from that um but just
like watching the the way the police
operate in this way and just like
grabbing someone like oh don't even help
a person who's bleeding out of their
head I mean and watching them um
kettling Pro peaceful protesters I mean
I was out in the streets protesting I've
seen the police violence you know
firsthand and and so the idea that like
you know oh we can fix this with
training is I think kind of a pipe dream
and I think that well and one thing real
quick just before you move on from the
the Rochester example because I think
that's like a perfect example of of the
two perspectives right you've got one
where uh people see a video and a cop
basically shove for those haven't seen
the video they shove a 70 something year
old man uh he stumbles backwards and
eventually Falls over kind of lands on
his you know on his ass then his back
hits and then his head slams into the
concrete uh I I believe he uh had like a
um he was bleeding from his head right
and basically the police walk right by
him what later came out was the police's
argument was we said over and over and
over again uh clear the square clear the
square where he was standing they didn't
comply with the police and therefore we
moved through and and that was kind of
um you know a side effect of us going to
to kind of quotequote do our job and
where I always kind of find the nuances
well hold on a second these two things
can actually be true at the same time
right of hey you can say we told
everyone to leave the square they didn't
do what we said we have a job to do and
therefore we went and executed our job
and still at the same time it be true
that okay but you still should
push over a 70 something year old man
slam his head on the ground and walk by
as if nothing happened and basically
treat your fellow citizens as if they
don't matter or you have some right to
do that to them and and and to me it was
always this like Middle Ground of like
how do you implement the Nuance right
because I think com people with common
sense can talk through it but in the
moment how do you get two American
citizens to realize in that moment that
they not are they're actually not on
different teams they should be somehow
on the same team and that's what I just
I can't wrap my head around how you
implement it you know I think that some
of it is well first of all I I was
thinking about the Rochester Police
because that was the murder of Daniel PR
the 41y old man who was um unwell and
they put a bag over his face and killed
him but the this was the Buffalo police
who shoved the 75y old man over who slam
fell backwards and hit his head and um
and then they released a statement
saying he tripped and fell and was
injured which obviously was not the
truth um and and I think you know there
was just there's a lot that that came
out about that but I think that when we
think about the fact that you know
billions of dollars of our of our
budgets are allocated to policing to
surveillance to punishment instead of
into fostering Equitable and healthy and
safe communities you know that is a way
that we all I think we all can come
together on that issue because it seems
to me that when police have to respond
to mental health emergencies you know
like Daniel prud like many other you
know people who've recently been killed
in police encounters
like they shouldn't be responding to
mental health issues they they shouldn't
be the ones they're ill equipped to deal
with it you know we should have mental
health professionals doing that but to
do that we need to invest in in our
communities we need to invest in you
know supporting people in Social
Services for mental health for domestic
violence for homelessness we need to
fund schools and hospitals and housing
in those communities because that is
what will keep us safe and so I think
that we need to focus government budgets
on programs Beyond policing as like an
essential step to achieving those goals
yeah what what is so true about what
you're saying right now is uh I've got a
lot of friends who are cops used to be
cops right just coming from the military
um it's a natural kind of career path
for them to pursue at the state at the
federal and the local level and what
people don't realize is soldiers if you
talk to them are usually the first to
say do everything you possibly can not
to go to war right because they've seen
it they they understand what war is and
they say if you send me I am going to do
what you are sending me to do but you
should do everything in your power not
to go to war and and they're not
pacifist in the traditional sense but
they are absolutely uh deterrence of
violent engagement with other nations
when I talk to Cops what I find so
fascinating is there's a similar element
of exactly what you're saying they're
saying why are we sending men with guns
right men or women with guns to respond
to a mental health issue or to something
elsea it's it's almost like you know
somebody scrapes their knee and we show
up with surgeons and the surgeons are
ready to do surgery but all they needed
was a Band-Aid and and so I think that's
part of what you're talking about here
is like is it actually our idea of what
the quote unquote police or the
responding force can be is almost it
matches the threat in some way like like
the person who's a mental health
situation doesn't need somebody with a
gun they need somebody who can help them
with the situation that they're in right
exactly it's so we want to take away
responsibilities from police officers
that they themselves don't want you know
there are all kinds of Mental Health and
Social Work functions that are rarely if
ever improved by someone showing up with
a
gun yep it it it makes a lot of sense
and then talk a little bit just about
the police immunity uh topic so my
understanding is that whether it's the
Buffalo police um and a whole number of
other uh police forces around the uh
country we've seen over and over again
something happens generally the public
opinion immediately is hey that was bad
uh that's not what we want our police
officers to do uh sometimes the police
officer is at fault sometimes it's just
they're in in a situation and they
endend up doing something um you it's a
reaction they're humans they make
mistakes whatever it is regardless of
kind of intentionality it's something
that ends up being misconduct and in
that
situation any other job people get fired
people get fined they they lose pay they
lose rank like like what whatever the
the the the uh repercussion is with
police officers that's not necessarily
the case because of this kind of
overarching immunity to a lot of what
they do and so how do you think about
that so when people talk about uh
qualified immunity which is the you know
the doctrine that Shields government
officials from being held personally
liable for
constitutional violations um this is a
you know a a statute that exists but
this is this is about that's about um uh
their their monetary their civil
liability you know in terms of what we
would do to fix um the the problems that
I see with the the way in which police
misconduct is handled you know the
Manhattan district attorney cyance has
been complicit in the continuing
misconduct perpetrated by the NYPD and
instead of using his power to hold them
accountable he has used his power to
shield and protect police officers
including you know the ones who
perpetrate you know brutal assaults um
who falsify documents who who lie under
oath um and explain that a little bit
when you talk about Shield
just so most people they don't see this
every day right so like what do you mean
by that in terms of the district
attorney is shielding police officers
well you know if an average citizen
walking down the street pulled out a
baton and hit someone over the head with
it who was doing nothing wrong that
person would be charged with assault if
the average person got behind a car a
the wheel of a car and drove a car into
like a a group of people that person
would be charged probably with attempted
murder um if a person got up on the
stand in court and said do you swear to
tell the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth I do and lied
under oath that person would be charged
with perjury yet we see over and over
and over again police officers engaging
in these different behaviors committing
crimes and not being held accountable
and you know this is you know I think
there's a huge problem with the way in
which DA's offices and the police are so
deeply intertwined and so District
Attorneys across the country we've seen
a huge problem with the accountability
on on the part of holding police
accountable by the district attorney you
know and and I I've talked about this a
lot and I say that you know when I after
I win my election and become Manhattan
da I will establish a dedicated unit
that is specifically designed to
prosecute police misconduct and when
there's accountability for True police
misconduct our communities will be safe
safer and that is how we will restore
trust and
integrity I think we see eye to eye on
this is it fair to say that you agree
that majority of police officers do the
right thing go to work every day want to
make a living go home Etc and the
problem is there's a minority that do
misconduct bad behavior and kind of like
the bad apples spoil it for everybody or
do you disagree with that you know it's
hard to it's hard to say because first
of all there is so there's so there's so
little transparency and accountability
we don't I don't know that we
necessarily know but I think that that
that police leadership if that is any if
we can Garner anything if we can take
anything away from police leadership the
overwhelming hostility the leadership
has shown to even the mildest of reforms
and accountability measures uh certainly
mean that it's going to be a a difficult
road to to go down um I I would hope and
I know that there are police officers
out there who you know went into went
into law enforcement for the right
reasons who don't want to be um out
there brutalizing people or engaging in
in some of these these behaviors but but
I think the problem is just the way in
which this this system operates right
now the what not only like what we've
asked police officers to do such as
policing those who are who are um
mentally ill or who are poor or who are
who are suffering from substance use
disorder but I I mean I think the police
should want to to be free from those
obligations you know to stop punishing
people and and arresting people for
those things um but it's going to take
like a a really a pretty pretty big
overhaul of the mindset of of the whole
you know the whole Force yeah one of the
last things I want to talk about the
police and then I want to move on
because I know we got a ton of other
topics to cover is um I listened to I
think it was the police Union Chief and
I may have that incorrect so if I do uh
somebody correct us but um he basically
gave a a speech at one point earlier
this year and one of the data points
that he presented that I found um
counter to what I had thought was he
basically said look if you take the
total number of interactions that uh he
was talking specifically about the New
York Police Department have with
constituents and then you look at the
ones in which there is misconduct
reported issues Etc it's a very very
small percentage I don't remember the
exact percentage but it was like
abnormally low compared to what I
thought it was right that the way that
they reported it was like I almost want
to say 1% and maybe I've got that wrong
but it was like very very small number
and the other data point that was
interesting in as he was talking about
this was just how many interactions the
New York police department has with
constituents and so I think you know
we've already talked about kind of if
you don't have police go to every single
time somebody calls 911 and you've got
other people you can take down the
number of times that the police have to
interact with people right and kind of
save them for uh the more um uh
appropriate things that they're trained
to do but how do you look at is it a
thing where like the number of bad
incidents are actually not great from a
uh an aggregate number but the severity
is really bad or is it maybe that the
the reporting is wrong like like how do
you kind of just think through and maybe
even have a number of like percentage of
police interactions are falling into
this category of like misconduct or or
things that if people saw them would say
hey that's not what we want the police
to
do uh so I I mean I I'm not looking at
the data points that you're referencing
so I would need to see them but if
they're coming from the police directly
I think that you know there would
definitely be push back from a lot of
activism groups and and um organizing
groups and people on the ground uh
because I think in carrying out the way
that the NYPD engages in their quota
driven you know broken windows tactics
they have uh an extremely high number of
punitive interactions with New Yorkers
um every year so I I think um you know
this
is uh I think it's it's it's a much
higher number than than what you just
cited um but I don't have exact
percentages in that's fine and that's
helpful um let's move on to uh I want to
talk about the War on Drugs uh mainly
because it feels like uh there is um a
change happening Across America right in
New York um is kind of one piece of it
but but Across America and my
understanding of this is you know a
couple decades ago we basically decided
as a country drugs are bad and we're
going to go and enforce the law and if
you are engaged in drugs either as uh
somebody who is uh importing them
somebody who is selling them or somebody
who is consuming those drugs we are
going to uh put you in jail we're going
to punish you Etc now with the hindsight
bias of many decades of data I think
that we've seen one uh this War on Drugs
may not be nearly as effective as uh we
once hoped two there are certain people
who have a disproportionate um kind of
impact in that war of drugs or or
they're targeted or or or arrested uh
and then three is this change that's
occurring is basically uh now as we saw
um in the in the uh recent voting around
the election uh there are states that
are choosing to decriminalize certain
drugs or to legalize certain types of
drugs and so maybe just let's start kind
of from a high level how you see the war
on drugs and kind of what the current
situation uh there is in terms of
policing and sentencing and and the
entire Criminal Justice System yeah well
you know I I I think the the War on
Drugs is not a War on Drugs it's a war
on people
um black and brown people poor people
people with disabilities um and I think
we've seen now that there's no uh
material difference between blacks and
whites for the use of drugs or the sale
of drugs but if you're black you are
more than three times more likely to be
arrested for those crimes um we exist
within a profoundly racist system um and
we live in a nation where now there are
more black men uh incarcerated or under
criminal supervision than the entire
number who were enslaved in
1850 so I mean the characterization of
the War on Drugs being anything other
than a way to continue to marginalize
people of color to um prosecute and jail
people with substance use disorder or
mental health issues um or just simply
those who are poor um is is just
completely untrue and I think that you
know the only way to fix this is by
decriminalizing ing all drugs um we need
to I mean it's far past time that we
should legalize marijuana expe all
previous convictions I mean that is and
reinvest in the communities that were
disproportionately harmed by by these
these you know Draconian laws but but I
think that that it really needs to be
all laws and and we did we had a huge
Victory um I think that across across
the country we've seen people uh really
coming around to this position and
recognizing that you know that that
rehabil itation and treatment and um
helping people is much more important
than than just incarcerating them for
for for drug crimes so and this is I'm
going to go really deep in the weeds
here uh my understanding of um the
number of people who get arrested for
drug possession right or intent to sell
or or whatever uh is a proxy or or kind
of an effect of
where we police right and so the extreme
example and very much an
overgeneralization but just to kind of
highlight that the difference is um if
you have somebody standing on the street
corner uh in a neighborhood and they are
selling drugs versus you have somebody
consuming it in a Suburban home right
there tends to be race intertwined there
but just the ability for the police to
drive by on a street corner and arrest
somebody um and understand they're
selling drugs is very different than
their ability to go into your private
home you know outside of a metro area
Etc how much of this is uh the again
socioeconomic the urban environment like
that type of stuff and therefore that
leads to race being involved verse do
you think it is literally we are turning
a blind eye to one part of the
quotequote drug problem in America right
so like prescription narcotics would be
a great example of uh Hey that may be
even worse right and if you kind of look
at deaths like that's pretty bad uh
compared to uh while we're turning a
blind eye to one part we're actually
targeting uh another type of drug
another type of uh consumption uh
dealing
Etc yeah I mean I think that you
know our approach to um to to thinking
when we think about like Criminal
Justice Reform including drug policy
requires like really transformational
like outof the-box thinking it can't
just be the way that we've always
thought about things you know this this
ineffectual like oh just say no approach
is just it simply doesn't work it's just
it's completely flawed and it ignores
all of the public health concerns and it
it disproportionately harms people um
and so I think that you know we should
be treating the public health issue that
exists as a public health issue and not
criminalizing and punishing it um for
for people who who struggle with
substance use disorder and uh you know I
think that we've seen the surging number
of opioid overdose deaths um not just
here in New York but across the country
and we should be supporting you know
safe safe consumption sites we should be
supporting evidence-based treatment we
should be supporting opportunities that
provide people with um you know
stability and uh I think that this is
something that like we have to approach
with a um with like an eye towards like
seeing the humanity in each and every
person um you know I think that there's
so much of our criminal legal system
that exists that it just dehumanizes
people on such a a like massive level I
mean you'll hear even just the wording
that people use when people say oh that
person's a criminal a felon a convict an
inmate prisoner um a drug addict a a
whatever they just refer to it's not
they're not human and so like when we
approach these things with compassion
with thinking about people as people
people first you know say oh a person
who a person who is suffering from
substance use disorder a person who is
currently incarcerated a person who has
been convicted of a crime so as not to
define the person by the thing um you
know then we can actually think about
these ways of transformationally
changing our approach and and I think
that when we think about about how to
approach these these issues with drugs
like we just need to think about what
kinds of impacts these have on human
beings like if we think about each
person who we lock up for a drug
possession crime being someone's mother
someone's father someone's partner
someone's sibling Someone's Child then
maybe we can have oh my God like this is
a massive impact on not just that person
but their entire family their entire
community and we are actually making
them you know we're not doing anything
to treat the underlying issue and then
they're going to cycle back through the
system and you know nothing that we do
while we incarcerate people helps them
like kick a drug habit for example and
like far too often as a public defender
I'd seen clients who who wanted so
desperately to get better and the
Manhattan DA's office instead of being
like yeah absolutely that is definitely
a person who could use a treatment
program says no no we don't think that
person's worthy for one reason or
another and like treatment should be the
rule rather than the exception we should
be giving everyone who who wants it
treatment for for drug use yeah
you mentioned a safe consumption site
and this will kind of lead us I think
into kind of the orgon what happened
there uh recently but explain just what
is a safe consumption site yeah so um I
think people call them safe consumption
sites or supervised consumption sites
which are you know facilities that are
medically supervised and designed to
provide a safe place for those who are
dealing with a substance use disorder um
and usually it's like you know it goes
in conjunction with like a harm
reduction approach towards drug problems
and the facility provides a you know
sterile injection equipment um provides
information about drugs Health Care
treatment referrals access to medical
staff um and you know Pro uh prohibits
the sale or or you know purchase of
drugs but but basically it allows people
to and I think you know we we really
hear about it in terms of like I think
in the Netherlands and and other places
where it's like a place where people can
drop in and and they have these centers
that are needle exchanges that are that
where people can receive support and um
it actually helps reduce drug use reduce
um you know overdose deaths reduce uh
and reduce crime and so like those are
the kinds of things that we really need
to be thinking about um here in the
United States like across the board so
again let's go to kind of the extremes
and and uh I always caveat this stuff
with like we live in such a divisive
society and using the extremes of that
division is great to highlight the
differing opinions uh but I wish people
would meet in the middle um is kind of
the the solution but I think that when
people hear this so there would be one
side that says this is amazing uh we can
actually reduce drug use we can reduce
crime um kind of treat people with
Humanity like all the things that you
just said sound fantastic right that
that's kind of one perspective there's
another perspective that says oh my God
El are you guys crazy you're going to
just help people do drugs right and
again the reason why I say like meeting
in the middle is like there's usually a
lot of common sense in moderation and
and kind of you know the central
Viewpoint um how do you think through or
or communicate to the people who are in
the extreme view of like you just want
to help people do drugs right and like
you you want to provide sterile needles
but like you're still helping them kind
of continue a habit what is the argument
or the articulation that you think can
kind of pull those people more towards
the center of no there is a benefit to
this and and there is a kind of a
positive uh impact that can happen um
you know by simply just putting let's
say these supervised consumption sites
or or something else well so I think
that the thing that most people want is
to feel safe in in the city in which
they live they want to be able to walk
their kids down the street they want to
feel safe they don't want to see people
you know shooting up on the street it
makes them feel unsafe now whether or
not it actually makes them unsafe is is
a different story but it makes them feel
unsafe and I think that that when we
talk about like the the what the actual
literal data shows like you can look at
the numbers and you say oh look if we if
we remove one of the most common
justifications for law enforcement to
harass arrest you know prosecute
incarcerate and Deport people um which
is drug crimes we see a a a a effect on
the way in which that uplifts all people
the way in which that helps cities um
become safer you know we see crime goes
down we see uh when we shift to
prioritize health over punishment we see
you know I think that that it they're
predicting um in Oregon that the the
felony and misdemeanor convictions for
drug possession now with with the new
ballot measure they just passed um will
go down by
91% I mean that is a that is an
unbelievable number and if you also
think about it fiscally I think there
are so many people who are like like so
their their default is send people to
jail but but when you think about the
fact that for taxpayers and I can't
speak to anywhere except for except for
New York City but but when you send
someone to Riker's Island in New York
City that costs taxpayers $975 a
night I mean that is that's wildly
expensive for taxpayers I mean people
more than a hotel more than a very nice
hotel like you could stay in a nice
hotel room for that amount of money or
you could get an apartment for a month
for for some people you know you could
get a room you could get and for much
less than that for much less for like
dollars uh you know we can invest in
people and make it so they don't cycle
back through and so we are actually
saving taxpayers money um so for those
who who maybe don't buy the The
Compassion argument or the humanity but
if they fiscally care about where their
tax dollars are going they can say to
themselves well I would rather spend you
know x amount of dollars up front and
then not pay the $975 a night for every
time that person continues to get
arrested and get incarcerated and get
locked up on Riker's Island which they
will continue to do if we do nothing if
we don't think about the long-term
consequences if we don't think about how
using our criminal legal system for
substance use is
counterproductive and I think that you
know I I mean I I feel like oregonians
are really leading the way and I'm I'm
so like heartened to see these these
real um reform measures pass across the
country and show that people have a real
appetite for this yeah so for those that
don't know um recently there was a
ballot measure that was put forward in
Oregon uh and basically there are a
couple of different nuances to it but
the the general takeaway is that uh the
organ voters decided or chose to and I
think it still needs to be ratified but
at least the the majority of people
voted to to decriminalize uh basically
hard drugs so I think it's uh heroin uh
meth LSD uh maybe cocaine's in there or
not but just B basically drugs that you
would consider a hard drug will now be
decriminalized the um understanding I
have of the decriminalization means that
if you are in possession of a minor
amount of these drugs uh or you are
actively using them when uh you
encounter the police they will not
arrest you instead what they will do is
they will give you a fine I think I
think the uh the amount right now seems
to be about $100 uh and that $100 fine
can be waved um if you agree to
basically some sort of treatment-based
uh protocol right and there's some
pre-approved program and basically if
you go through that program then they'll
go ahead and they'll remove the the
financial fine so that was kind of one
part of it was uh what I'll call the
decriminalization of hard drugs the
second piece was uh the
legalization of um some psychedelic um
compound uh it's the most popular one
found in mushrooms and uh it's
specifically being legalized for use in
mental health treatment so in supervised
used uh kind of medical type
environments uh with specific use cases
but I think that Oregon to your point is
um really uh at the Forefront of doing
this and the argument that I've heard is
uh basically the Portugal argument right
Portugal in 2001 decided they were going
to decriminalize all drug uh use and
consumption and they basically just said
look we're not going to treat this as a
crime instead we're going to focus on
Rehabilitation uh I think most people
think that it's proven to be pretty
effective in Portugal uh there's still
some people who say this is an absolute
nightmare we should have never done it
whatever but I think the general
consensus is like this was a positive
and so now that Oregon's going to do it
uh it sounds like they're basically
goingon to try to replicate the
experiment that's played out for the
last 20 years in Portugal and say look
if we focus on the rehabilitation that
changes the relationship that people
have with the criminal justice system is
that is that kind of how you see the at
least the goal of what they're trying to
accomplish yeah absolutely and if you
think about the the fact that you know
someone could be charged with possessing
a a such a like a tiny amount of drugs
they get charged they end up pleading
guilty they now have a criminal record
this excludes them from jobs from
housing from loans from you know and
this this makes it's it's like a
sometimes even though it's only like
they got a very minimal sentence when it
came to the actual crime they're
sentenced to a lifetime of unemployment
or difficulty you know Finding getting
into school or or getting into homes so
so you think about what that does to
somebody saddling them with a with a
criminal record over minor possession of
drugs something that they were that was
for personal use um it's it's really
like a a huge change and you know what
we have seen in Portugal is that there
was no surge in drug use people who say
oh well if you decriminalize now
everybody's going to use drugs but it
turns out that's not in fact what
happened that there was no increase in
in usage but the deaths the number of
deaths from drugs fell significantly and
the number of people who were able to
access treatment who wanted treatment
for for substance use disorder Rose
significantly and and so I think it's
just like such a huge step in moving
towards a health-based approach instead
of just criminal pun punishment um and
so I think ultimately it ends up saving
your state or your country money to do
that as well is it possible that we
could see decriminalization of all drugs
in New York state or New York City like
is is that a is that a world where um
the environment in which we all live
could stomach that and kind of get the
uh votes needed to pass something like
that do you
think it's possible um I think we have
an upheld battle I mean we haven't even
legalized marijuana here in New York
that's what I want to talk about next we
are fighting tooth and nail for that
which I do actually think is likely to
happen in the next legislative session
but I think that what we can do in the
interim is elect me as Manhattan
district attorney because I am committed
to saying you know what this is what's
so wild about about da positions is they
are just so immensely powerful because
even if there's a law on the books as
district attorney it will be within my
discretion to decide what crimes get
prosecuted how they get prosecuted who
gets prosecuted who gets the opportunity
for treatment whether someone gets sent
to jail you know and one of the things
that I'm very committed to is
decriminalizing drug possession meaning
even if New York state has not enacted
legislation to do that I will not
prosecute people for for low-level drug
possession it's just it's just simply it
doesn't keep us safe it doesn't um you
know stop recidivism it doesn't address
the public health issues people are
facing and instead it Saddles people
with criminal records it tears families
apart um you know and it it destroys
people's lives by charging them with
crimes when when really what we could do
is think about um uh you know ways of
doing this like what Oregon's doing like
what Portugal has done to to Really um
facilitate something that would that
would just bring like a better future
for everyone so you you just described
something that uh is not a new idea I
think we've actually seen I think it was
the Baltimore da basically said look the
decriminalization happens one of two
ways either we change the laws or we
stop enforcing the laws and as the da um
I believe it was an African-American uh
woman as the da she said look I grew up
in these communities I'm not going to
enforce these laws uh and I think it was
specifically around um kind of minor
possession of marijuana specifically
right so not kind of all drugs I think
it was just marijuana um and what it did
do it change the police Behavior right
because the police said uh if I keep
arresting somebody but we're not going
to enforce the like we're not going to
go after them we're not going to try to
convict them then what's the point of
even arresting them and and it was
almost like this like pseudo
decriminalization because of the da
decided and made it publicly known I'm
not going to uh prosecute these cases
and that's really what it sounds like
you're talking about in terms of not
just around marijuana but you would um
effectively try to do that across all
drugs uh you know low-level drug type uh
crimes exactly and it's it's very
similar to what Marilyn Mosby the da in
Baltimore did with regards to marijuana
possession she basically said is law
enforcement and possession you know of
marijuana making us safer as a city and
the answer is emphatically no like do we
need to prosecute this if we scale back
prosecutions if we end prosecutions if
we decriminalize will we make our city
safer and in fact as it turns out you
know they dropped all these cases and it
actually
did help it didn't it didn't you know
utilize police resources squander police
resources really by by Prosecuting
people and arresting people for for drug
possession um you know uh nobody thinks
I don't think that anybody thinks that
using resources to jail people for
marijuana is good use of resources um I
think that has become pretty universally
accepted um you know I think more and
more people are coming on board with
that with regards to to all uh low-l
drug possession and especially with the
use of of certain um therapeutic the
therapeutic use of certain drugs to
treat PTSD but I think that there are so
many amazing studies going on including
at John's Hopkins at other you know
really prominent medical institutions
that are showing that these drugs these
drugs have been able to treat people for
whom treatment has been impossible with
traditional means and I think a lot of
those people are War veterans um you
know I've I've represented a number of
clients who came back from serving in
Iraq or Afghanistan and suffered from
pretty severe PTSD and all the
traditional methods of treatment whether
it be you know just um prescription
medication or or talk therapy or or
other ways that people typically get
treated were unsuccessful and it led to
you know a spiral and and a cycle and a
life that that was really I don't think
one that they that they wanted to be
engaged in you're being uh incredibly
kind uh I I go pretty hard on the
legalization of marijuana only because
uh one it's a damn plant right two is uh
we're basically putting people in jail
for smoking a plant uh three is you ever
seen anyone who's overdosed right or
who's kind of done anything that you
would associate with maybe the harder
drugs or alcohol or anything like that
uh and then on top of that uh we live in
a world where right now you or I could
go invest in cannabis businesses but if
we walk down the street with cannabis in
our pocket we end up getting arrested
and then there's just this crazy uh um
disconnection right between what you can
do with your money versus what you can
do with your body uh and and it just
feels like uh that is something that's
going to fall right I I uh used to think
that it would take a very long time but
now even in conversations with people
who tend to be uh much older right much
wealthier uh or not as wealthy like it's
just across the Spectrum uh you are
seeing more and more people warm up to
the idea and say you know what like yeah
it's about time that uh that we go ahead
and legalize this and there's momentum
right kind of of nationally uh you're
you're seeing different states um kind
of do this so it feels like that'll
happen at some point uh it sounds like
you think it could happen to you know
relatively quickly um in the next
legislative session I hope so I hope so
um I think you know it's just there's
there's really there's really no
justification you're absolutely right
there's no justification for um it
continuing to remain illegal and I'm
hopeful that that you know we're seeing
it fall even even this week we saw
legislation passed
um that permits the use in I mean New
Jersey legalized um
Montana uh I think couple States yeah
there are like a handful of states and
you know this is now there are I think
36 states that have um legal
distribution for medical marijuana and
so I think that you know we're getting
closer and closer to to being able to um
pass this across the board so before we
move on from uh kind of this War on
Drugs topic my last question is um if
marijuana is legalized do we just go let
everyone out of jail who uh was
previously arrested for marijuana uh
possession or H how does that kind of
mechanically work right and and one of
the things I've kind of thought through
is like that's a lot of people right and
and so there's an argument of like hey
get those people out of jail as soon as
possible right because now they're
basically in jail for a crime that is no
longer a crime uh there's a whole
another argument around
uh how do you execute the release of you
know a million plus people or or a
couple hundred thousand people um and
kind of how does that work what's your
perspective on like if marijuana is
legalized uh you know in all 50 states
what do we do with the people who are
already in prison for low-level
marijuana
crimes um I mean first of all we should
definitely release all of them from jail
uh you know I think I you you know the
way you describe it is like something's
going to happen and all of a sudden
we'll snap our fingers and everyone will
be released it's not it's never going to
be that simple you know even if you know
first of all there are some that are
that are incarcerated for federal and
then every state would have to P you
know so it's there's so many different
overlapping um things but I think not
only should we be letting everyone out
of jail who is incarcerated for a
marijuana offense but we should be
expunging their criminal record and
probably um you know I don't even think
that goes far enough I think we we owe
them reparations for the victims uh uh
of America's mindless war on marijuana
and uh you know the the damage that the
prohibition of cannabis has done um is
is probably irreparable and it has
destroyed people's lives it has
destroyed families um and I think it
will uh continue on
for forever and you know here here we
are even in places where we're seeing it
legalized and there are all of these
people who were not harmed by by this in
by this you know criminalization of
marijuana and now they're poised to run
big marijuana businesses and cash in and
and make many many millions of dollars
maybe more um as opposed to you know
impoverished black kids who ended up in
prison for for possessing or selling
weed and whose families and Futures were
destroyed so I think you know it's it's
so important that not only that we
legalize but that we that we you know
atone for the harms that were committed
uh because of this so to play Devil's
Advocate on that one I know for sure
there's going to be a bunch of people
who listen to this and say wait a second
why would we ever atone for something
where somebody quotequote broke the law
at the time right and I think that again
I always think of these things is kind
of a spectrum you're GNA have a whole
community of people who say marijuana
should never be legal and anyone who
thinks that is you know an absolute
psychopath and uh it's a drug it's
illegal and like it should stay that way
I think that that that population is
getting much much smaller over time
right there's a bunch of people now and
and the increasing population is like
hey this is pretty ridiculous we should
legalize marijuana okay then it's what
do we do with those who've already been
convicted again I think that you got a
growing but still small group of people
who say we should let people out of
prison who were previously convicted
because it's no longer a crime I think
that that actually I've got pretty deep
conviction that like that population is
going to grow very quickly right and
that'll become a very popular kind of
position of just like if it's ille if it
was illegal you got arrest it but now
it's not illegal why are you still in
jail type thing right where I think the
uphill battle and and I have a hard time
seeing it be becoming popular as like oh
we let people out of jail and then also
whether it's Financial or some other
kind of atonement for having put people
in jail you then get in this like
slippery slope of like okay well what
other crimes were committed that now
aren't crimes do we go and like is it
just drugs is it across the board you
know kind how do you think through
um like identifying and almost like
drawing the box of like this is what 's
atonement for and like this is what
there it's not right and maybe we're not
even close enough to having to make
those decisions to have those Frameworks
but just how do you think about that
well I think that that's yes certainly
we are we're nowhere near having those
conversations I think like we we start
with you know getting people out of jail
and and expunging criminal convictions
because if you think about what a
criminal conviction over substance use
leads to it is you know mounting
economic difficulties because it limits
access to housing to employment to
student loans which make recovery more
difficult for all those people and you
know about like it's not like this has
always existed but it was these harsher
sentences that that kind of cropped up
coupled with like racist and reactionary
policies that meant that people could be
incarcerated and prosecuted for even
like the tiniest amount of marijuana um
you know if you think about the culture
of of criminalization that has stretched
like Beyond policing and incarceration
even it has fueled like widescale
militarized policing it has cost
taxpayers over1 trillion dollar um and
has like really expanded punitive
institutions um and Punishment oriented
systems in places Beyond just prisons
it's in schools in hospitals in social
service agencies and so like this has
been it's been a massive failure as well
like you know and and I'm so glad to see
now so many people changing their tune
about drug criminalization in general
but I think that shift in thinking was
spurred on by the fact that the opioid
addiction predominantly impacted white
people and I think that at its core drug
policy and criminalization is an issue
of racial Justice and that is why now we
have been able to see
um white people get on board with
decriminalization of drugs because of
the opioid crisis impacting um not just
black and brown people so I got to ask
when you bring up the opioid crisis uh
we've seen Purdue Pharma and uh kind of
the entire I don't know I'll steal the
military industrial complex and say the
the prescription industrial complex um
what you know as the da you would have
immense power uh and make a lot of
decisions how do you view um you know
going after the organizations that now
you know there are uh certain whether
they're federal or state bodies going
after them both civil and criminally I
think or at least investigating um how
do you kind of think about the
implementation of laws when it comes to
the opioid stuff not just you know meth
LSD marijuana cocaine Etc well so what's
so fascinating is you know as someone
who spent my entire career as a public
defender I have
represented I mean countless people who
were charged with possession of drugs
and yet you know the doctors who are
overprescribing and taking Kickbacks the
pharmaceutical Industries who are who
are preying on people you know those are
not people who are being held
accountable and it really just kind of
feeds right into all that I talk about
when I say you know how rigged our
criminal legal system is our criminal
punishment bureaucracy which is designed
to to punish those who are who are poor
who are powerless who are people of
color and meanwhile those who are
wealthy who are well-connected and
typically who are white get off with no
accountability and and that includes you
know certainly the the drug industry
that includes all of these people who
who have who have really perpetuated
this um opioid crisis and yet the people
who are charged and incarcerated for
using drugs are the ones who are held
accountable and then those who are
extremely wealthy and well-connected and
Powerful or not and we see it across the
board like we see that with so many
things if you think about the fact that
like I represent people routinely who
are charged with with you know minor
theft offenses like someone who goes
into a CVS and steals you know Reese's
peanut butter cups or a pint of ice
cream you know things worth like four or
five dollars and yet and they are
charged Ed with a crime they're arrested
and jailed and charged and yet there are
employers out there who are committing
wage theft to the tune of millions or
tens of millions or hundreds of millions
of dollars and they are not held
accountable no one is Prosecuting them
and who is that harming well that's
harming our communities that's harming
everyday people who don't have the power
to fight back when their employer is is
skimming off their paycheck and so you
know as da like this is what I want to
do I want to make sure that that people
are held accountable that everyone that
no one is above the law that the same
law applies to everyone and that that
just because you're powerful
well-connected wealthy you don't get to
to to buy your way out of
accountability yeah what what uh um is
always fascinating to me is like the
criminal label and the uh application of
the law flows down to the most
Elementary uh application of it right
and basically it is that person who runs
in there's literally a CVS on the corner
where I live and there's a cop car
parked outside every day they got their
uh lights on no siren and they're a
deterrent and I can't tell you how many
times uh I have walked in there and
while I'm in the store I'm in the store
for less than 10 minutes somebody is
stealing something and it's gotten to
the point where what the cops will do is
they will literally just yell out the
window to the person who's leaving with
the stolen thing and the person will
walk back in and hand it back to the the
person on the cash register and I think
when people see that they're like oh my
God that's horrible like how could this
you know how could this happen over and
over and over and over again at the same
location and how do you stop it
whatever absolutely that's a problem and
that should be stopped and people
shouldn't walk into CVS and steal things
like I think everyone kind of agrees on
that but your point is the total
aggregate economic damage of all of that
is literally peanuts compared to what
happens when people are in boardrooms
white collar crime things like that and
one of the uh the the jokes that I
always share with people is you know the
people sending the prescription drugs
those are just drug dealers with cologne
there's what's the what's the difference
right by the way actually they're worse
the person on the street corner sure
they shouldn't be doing that right and
and given the laws today it's illegal
and all the stuff but like the
systematic kind of um implementation of
a sales and marketing strategy and and
and kind of all that stuff is way way
worse and has a way negative effect on
people compared to the one individual on
the street corner and it sounds like
your thought process is kind of we spend
a disproportionate amount of our
resources going after the person on the
street corner not necessarily going
after the person in the boardroom we do
we do and this is just you know what
we've seen time and time again and it's
just that you know we we see I mean I
talk about the current Manhattan da
because this is who I've gone up against
for over a decade but but sance has
routinely failed to hold those who are
wealthy and well-connected and Powerful
accountable well why do you think that
is you know I think that people he sees
them as His they're like the people that
he rubs shoulders with that he goes to
cocktail parties with you know the the
the Harvey Weinstein of the world who
have always been his his friends his
allies you know these are all like Rich
powerful white men and and so I think
that it's been difficult to you know a
lot of New Yorkers feel very betrayed by
the fact that that these people like
Harvey Weinstein who he didn't prosecute
for six years you know he had recorded
evidence that Harvey Weinstein was
committing sex crimes and yet did not
prosecute him until after Ronan pH rod
and expose and me to movement started
and public pressure mounted to the point
where he literally was given no choice
but to bring a prosecution um you know
he argued for leniency for Jeffrey
Epstein he didn't prosecute the Trump
kids um he gave like a a sweetheart deal
to that um Colombia OBGYN Dr Haden who
at the time they thought had had
sexually assaulted you know a handful of
his pregnant patients but it turns out
it was dozens maybe hundreds of of women
including Andrew Yang's wife Evelyn who
spoke out so bravely about you know her
her vict ation by this person but the
Manhattan DA's office gave him you know
a like a total like a deal that that my
clients who were charged with similar
things or even less would would never
have
gotten yeah I want to switch gears and
talk about sentencing and bail um maybe
let's talk about bail first and and at
as like a one1 level this will be super
Elementary for you but just for the uh
listeners and viewers help people
understand uh you get arrested there's
bail hearings and then there's kind of
the trial right right and then there's
the sentencing um just one is that
accurate from like a sequence standpoint
and then kind of what the issues are
that you see with those uh various touch
points whether it's the bail or or
sentencing so there are a bunch of
issues but basically the way that the
you know the track works is you get
arrested um you get brought to central
booking where you come up through
arraignments you meet your attorney for
the first time you go before a judge and
hear the charges against you and that's
where the initial bail determination is
made um and then you you know yes
theoretically if you're going to go to
trial that happens but but the process
is often the punishment you know people
come back to court for years sometimes
before they get their day in court uh
and then there is a post-trial
sentencing but also fewer than 5% of
cases go to trial because the system is
not designed to take cases to trial
despite the fact that that's what we see
in the media that every case on Law and
Order goes to trial what we're really
seeing is you know upwards of 90% of
cases resulting in a plea of some sort
and people plead guilty for different
reasons you know there's what's called a
trial tax meaning if you know the the
DA's
office basically says if you take this
case to
trial the you know we will be seeking
the maximum sentence we'll be seeking X
number of years X number of decades um
but if you plead guilty right now you
can have this great deal of six months
or of probation or of whatever and they
they make it so that the consequences of
taking a case to trial are so severe and
extreme that you know most people take
pleas and that and so before we get to
the sentencing and and kind of pedial
part the bail process is kind of that
first step right so you've you've been
arrested you meet your attorney you go
in front of a judge and this is what you
were kind of alluding to uh earlier in
the conversation around basically if you
don't have money you're screwed right
it's the understanding and you know to
to kind of give you the context here
from my perspective I did not understand
this at all and I had um a a woman come
on who's building a company and and I
apologize I don't remember the name of
the company but basically it's a
for-profit company that specifically
uses technology to try to help people
pay bail so it's things like um you know
payment plans it's things like uh being
able to autodraft and and just all these
things that help give the government and
the legal process more confidence that
if we let you out on bail you will pay
us right um but talk a little bit about
the issues with uh baale
specifically so the the thing about bail
is that
bail the purpose the legislative purpose
of bail is supposed to be to ensure
someone's return to court just to make
sure that they come back for their court
dates and
you know when we set money bail on
someone all we are doing is making it so
that if that person does not have money
they will not afford to be able to buy
their freedom and so you know I've been
very outspoken that we must end cash
bail um the way what is Cash bail cash
bail money bail that you have to pay to
get
released got it and there are other
forms of bail so when we say so if you
say bail as like a general thing that
can mean other things such as um less
restrictive means such as supervised
release or electronic monitoring or um
you know a personal a personally secured
Bond uh where you just say yeah I swear
I'm G to come back to court you know and
and and so there's there's just there's
ample evidence that the vast majority of
people return to court without money
bail when you say vast are we talking
55% or no in the 90s in the in the high
80s 990s I think is is what we we've
really seen and you know we've really
been sold this this false choice between
Public Safety and
incarceration and it it just represents
such a a departure from the Law's intent
of ensuring someone's return to court
what bail ends up being is just about
the balance of what is in someone's bank
account and you know I've represented
clients who have been held in on as
little as $250 bail that may as well
that may as well have been a million
dollars you know for something like
jumping a Turn Style or stealing a
Snickers bar
and meanwhile when Harvey Weinstein was
finally charged and he was facing you
know extremely serious charges where he
if he'd been convicted on the top charge
would have been facing a mandatory life
sentence he was uh arraigned and given a
pre-arranged bond of a million dollars
uh not did not spend one single night in
jail before he was convicted Beyond a re
Reasonable Doubt and found guilty by a
unanimous jury of 12 and meanwhile the
people that I've represented have been
held in unable to pay bail they've lost
their jobs their beds in in shelters
they've lost their homes they've lost
their children they've lost you know
everything and cash bail really just
perpetuates this biased racist classist
nature of our system what and sorry to
interrupt but just what do you think the
solution is so if we get rid of cash
bail is it no bail is there some other
form that you think is right but like
how do you think about there's an issue
what's the solution in your mind so I
mean as I said there are less
restrictive means possible there are
methods of non- incarcerator pre-trial
monitoring um like services or
electronic monitoring or signature or
non-cash security bonds but the the
reality is like we need to
we need to make sure that we are not you
know continuing to uphold this two
systems of Justice one for the rich and
one for everyone else and you know the
only difference between the people who
were charged with offenses who were
sitting on Riker's Island and those who
were walking around our neighborhoods
and taking the trains and and going to
work was is the fact that they have
money and nothing else and they're not
there like there's no you know there's
this mis misnomer that like oh this
person can't get let out of jail because
they're more dangerous or more
threatening but it was never that it's
really just oh we're holding this person
in because they are poor and so you know
I think we need to be legislating this
and and we are seeing some changes on
the legislative level here in New York
we did you know pass bail reform which
was subsequently partially rolled back
but but still we are seeing some changes
um but also we need District Attorneys
who will not seek money bail and you
know I think that that again like when
you point to what the data shows like
places where we are not using money bail
crime is not going up and in fact people
who are not being held in jail who are
able to continue to go to work and
provide for their families and you know
they they still have to come back to
court and fight their you know it's
still they still have a possibility for
for sentencing later down the line but
people who truly get to utilize the
presumption of innocence of being
innocent until proven guilty those
people get better outcomes they are less
likely to reoffend they are you know
able to remain in their homes with their
families and their communities and and
that really does benefit all of
society if I was talking to somebody who
disagreed with you on this what would
their argument be for the downside of
getting rid of cash bail like is it just
they're intellectually lazy is it
they're scared of crime goes up like
like what would their argument be so
listen that I mean I can tell you
because it's it's what the New York Post
publishes on a daily basis so they they
really they do this thing where they
fearmonger about the worst case scenario
oh there's this one person and sometimes
you you'll hear it called the Willie
Horton effect um but it's like yes
inevitably is one person who gets
released who otherwise might have been
held in going to reoffend sure but to
use that to extrapolate to say oh
because of this one incident we should
now
uh make every single person remain in
jail just because they're they're not
wealthy enough to buy their way out no
of course not like the overwhelming
majority of people are better served
including you know everyone in in cities
and communities because of their you
know this increases Public Safety and so
you know I do think that there is a lot
of fearmongering it there is the fear of
this one Rogue case where someone gets
let out of jail who otherwise would have
had bail set and then reffect ends and
and of course like nobody wants that but
but that can't dictate the way in which
we treat all human beings absolutely uh
before I forget the uh woman that I was
thinking of earlier is fedra Ellis
lampkins uh she's the CEO of a company
called promise and uh she's been on the
podcast before really really interesting
uh kind of Technology based Solutions um
one of the other things that I want to
talk about a s sentencing uh obviously
uh there's all kinds of crazy issues
here one of
um I'll use the word fascinating uh but
but that has a positive connotation and
I mean it in a negative connotation uh
is this idea that a judge sits there and
says you know what Eliza you've been
arrested I've heard the case uh you are
guilty um and now I'm going to determine
how long you're going to go sit in jail
for as punishment and uh I can choose
between two years and 12 years for the
crime that you've committed um the
difference between two and 12 is quite
large right the difference between three
and four years doesn't sound like a lot
but that is 12 months of somebody's life
and
the um inability to constantly
remind of the gravity in a sentencing
scenario right if you do it all day you
could easily see somebody saying H three
or four years like it's just a machine
right it almost becomes like a um a a uh
non-event choosing between three and
four years but has such a Prof impact on
individuals and then when you kind of
extrapolate that out to just the
difference between two and 12 years and
how do I as an individual get to decide
whether you get the full extent um on a
sentencing basis or the minimum and or
where in between it just feels like
there is um the ability to have a lot of
introduction of bias and then when you
look at data you know as I've talked to
people things like uh if you are up for
if you're already in jail you so you've
been arrested you've been sentenced and
now you're up for um potentially getting
out right on kind of a shorter sentence
uh if you go in and you see the judge or
the the the person who makes the
decision uh and you are within like an
hour and a half of lunch you're more
likely to get
rejected right so actually you want to
be the 9:00 am scheduled slot you don't
want to be the 11:30 slot and they've
done this on you know across
jurisdictions Etc and it's literally
people are rushing get to lunch and so
it's now you you know you stay in jail
and so you you start to understand that
like the potential introduction of bias
usually means that there will be some
level of bias and doesn't have to be
race or socioeconomic it can literally
just be we're humans and I'm having a
bad day today right and so because I got
out of the cabin I stepped in a puddle
of water I'm pissed off and you know my
sentencing ends up being extra extreme
today from your seat you've probably
seen good and bad sentencing
what's your view on all of this so it's
it's really interesting that you ask
this and that you frame it in the way
that it's really the judge's decision
because I think that that's exactly what
the vast majority of people think that
oh awesome so if I'm wrong I'd love to
do that well no no no but it's not it's
not that you're wrong like listen the
judge certainly is the person who
typically makes the sentencing decision
but that is if there is a sentencing
decision to be made okay the problem is
District Attorneys have all the power
and it actually like usurps the judge's
power because what the da can do is say
oh I'm charging you with this crime and
let's say the crime has a sentence range
of um I'm trying to think of a crime
like assault in the second degree five
to seven years so so you're facing five
to S years as you say you know 12 months
still matters but that's like a pretty
that's like a pretty minimal range when
as ranges go um but the mandatory
minimum is five well let's say the da
says I will offer you a different charge
so like you're charge of the crime here
I'll depart down and I'll offer this
crime and you can get a sentence of you
know a six month split with with five
years probation meaning you do you do
six month the da basically becomes the
person determining the sentence by proxy
of force not forcing but uh offering a
plea deal that is so attractive exactly
so because of mandatory minimums that
exist the these are statuto mandated
sentences that cannot be reduced by the
judge so let's say on a case where the
minimum is five years and I've listen
I've had cases like this where the judge
has put so much pressure on the da and
said this person doesn't deserve five
years let alone more but I can't make an
offer because based on the mandatory
minimum this is all I can do and the
judges their hands are tied they're
completely powerless but the da often
overcharges so that they can leverage
guilty pleas from people who don't want
to run the risk of facing a prolonged
mandatory sentence like after trial or
from a judge and so people charged with
mandatory minimums will often plea to a
sentence that undercuts that and not
what a judge determines is best so the
judge has so little power to make
determinations about sentences
especially given that you know as I said
90% or more of cases are resulting in
pleas of some sort anyhow and so when
you're plea bargaining It's really
because the Das have so much power and
this is why local elections matter why
who you're electing to be your local
district attorney matters so much this
is what I've been trying to tell people
it's like the most important elected
position that you maybe don't know so
many people are like oh I didn't even
realize we elect RDA and yet that's the
person who every day walks into court
and says on behalf of the people of the
state of New York so the things that
they are doing are in your name you as
the taxpayer they're acting in your name
and so if you don't like the things that
they're doing you have to to get engaged
in your local government you know local
elections they matter you have to vote
these people out um and you know here I
am trying to like upend the system as a
public defender running for district
attorney who wants to see like real
reform like transformational change so I
I never understood how a lot of this
worked um and and thankfully I've never
been in a situation where uh it was on
the extreme end but the first time that
I got my eyes open to this I had a
speeding ticket right and uh this is
going to sound so uh non-important
compared to what you deal with every day
but I remember it was in North Carolina
uh where I grew up and uh I went into
courton I had a friend who's uh I think
like a friend of a friend's you know
brother or something was a lawyer and
basically I was talking to some friends
and they were like oh when you go in
like you can basically talk to uh I
didn't know what a DA was but the person
who who's basically against you right
and you can literally like negotiate
with them and so I remember going in
there and being like this is going to be
awesome like like I got to negotiate
right and when I got there I was shocked
there was a line of attorneys that were
literally lined up against the wall and
you know it's just traffic court so it's
not super serious and it's kind of just
mechanically going through everything
but each attorney would walk up and
basically say hey I got you know my
client was uh doing a 75 and a 60 um how
about we and then they would basically
offer something and the da would just
say like yes or no and then person would
walk over they'd go in front of the
judge and like the da would basically
say okay we're willing to do X you know
do you agree defendant yes okay and then
it would be done and so I walked up
there uh by myself no attorney and uh I
basically heard somebody else say uh
pretty similar to me you know I had a
whatever the speeding ticket was and so
I just offered the same thing that the
attorney had offered and the da said to
me uh okay yes but where's your attorney
I I don't have an attorney he's like we
need an attorney and I was like okay
I'll be right back and I literally
walked to the back of the room and I
found an attorney and I was like hey man
like how much is it going to cost for
you to walk up there with me I already
like he already said he's going to do it
but I need an attorney with me and when
I saw this the attorney like just
started laughing he was like oh yeah
like this is how this works and I
remember thinking to myself speeding
tickets is one thing but this idea of
negotiating with the da to Simply get
this push through and imagine if your
freedom was on the line and and what I
was dealing with was like I think
literally it was like a a moving
violation versus the speeding ticket
right and it like then you didn't have
to go get a course on your license yeah
exactly what whatever like again like so
so unimportant compared to what you deal
with on a daily basis but it was the one
time I saw this and I remember just
leaving there being like what a racket
like literally and and that was traffic
court but what you're basically saying
is the same mechanism occurs when it's
burglary when it's murder when it's
assault when it's like all of these much
much more serious things and the da
knows that there's going to be a
negotiation and therefore says you know
what you push that person and maybe that
is you know kind of a a level two
offense but I'm going to charge you with
a much higher offense to get you then to
plea down so that I almost go into the
room negotiating from a position of
power and posturing of course to get the
plea deal done but that's exactly what
they do and that's why electing someone
like me who's been a public defender who
understands like the grave implications
of each and every case that is charged
like is so critical like the leadership
of these offices is typically people
who've like never been on the other side
certainly not like seen those people as
human beings and it's like the the but
it's just such a wild amount of power
and that they do nothing you know the DA
has really perpetuated this lock them up
throw away the key mentality doesn't
think about people as people doesn't
think about their underlying issues or
how it affects their families or or how
we can really make changes um
and and I think that like this is these
are all the reasons why I'm running like
I really want to see how we can both
make these changes that help everyone
but also that that increase Public
Safety that just like make our society
better as a whole if I had a district
attorney here and I said to them hey you
people are negotiating you're
overcharging you're doing everything we
just described what would their defense
be like why do they how do they go to
sleep at night doing this like how do
they rationalize it or or explain it to
themselves or what think the advantage
of doing this
is um I think a lot of people who become
Das like really believe in
this
carceral punishment system that we have
they think oh well you know we should
lock people up who commit crimes we
should you know lock them up if they
commit minor crime like they it's just
that's what they believe and that you
know they've I also think like
historically you know it was the job of
the prosecutor to seek justice but in a
lot of prosecutorial offices including
here in New York it's really become that
the prosecutor seeks conviction that
like a win in their eyes is a conviction
that if someone gets sentence that is
that's a win and and that really
shouldn't be the prosecutor's role you
know the way that I would want to
measure success would be to think about
if
I you know got someone into a position
where then that I never saw them again
and they never ever ever crossed the
threshold of the courthouse or you know
got charged or ever came back through
our criminal legal system like that
should be the way in which we measure
success um and I think that that the way
that we'll do that is by you know
addressing like people's underlying
mental health and substance use disorder
and decriminalizing poverty and just
changing the focus um and and just
thinking about about human beings as
people are most prosecutors did they
previously serve as uh defendant
attorneys whether public defenders or or
in private practice or do they come from
some other Pipeline and again you know
there's always going to be outliers but
like what's the normal path to become a
prosecutor um most of them were like
assistant prosecutors like most of the
the pipeline had really just been you're
an assistant DA you work your way up
you're you know you're prosecutor for
life like prosecutors are going to
prosecute and this is what they do and
and it really I mean if you had told me
when I became a public defender oh Eliza
one day you're going to run for district
attorney I would have been like yeah
right I would never have believed it
because it would have seemed it seemed
so impossible but now like with this
kind of change that we're seeing across
the country with real reformers getting
elected to Da positions I mean like
Larry krasner in Philadelphia really
started the the the whole movement um
and now we have people like Rachel
Rollins in suffi county in Boston um you
know Kim Fox in Chicago chasa Budin who
was a public defender and is now San
Francisco's district attorney and you
know that opened the door for someone
like me to run and to really think about
you know the different ways in which we
could approach
prosecution I told a couple of friends
that you were coming on and uh naturally
being in uh in kind of the technology
world uh many of them live in San
Francisco and you just brought up the uh
the da there uh there is a uh belief in
certain circles that the DA's done a
great job there's also a belief that the
DA has done uh a horrible job and has
led to a lot of the challenges that the
city has around drug abuse and crime and
you know you always see kind of a viral
video of somebody runs into a CVS steals
a bunch of stuff and you know everyone
loves dunking on anyone in an elected
position so immediately it becomes you
know hey thanks so much to the DA you
know you're really doing your job type
stuff how do you think about a lot of
the things we've talked about from like
a hey here is how you can um kind of
holistic Al affect a
system how do you think about like the
transition time right because like I it
almost seems to me like if you said
tomorrow hey we're going to
decriminalize all drugs and you're
Portugal and you look back 20 years you
can basically say it worked or it didn't
but my guess is that like there's
probably I don't know six months 12
months 24 months where like everyone
goes wild it's kind of like when you you
know if you never drank you turn 21 what
does everybody do they go get so drunk
that like they get reminded of like hey
maybe I shouldn't drink that much right
uh how do you kind of think about that
transition period And I don't know
necessarily if like San Francisco
specifically is going through some sort
of transition period but just is there
um almost this like hey yes this isn't
GNA be smooth sailing as we make a
transition but like the ends justify the
means or or the transition like how do
you think about that well listen I think
that certainly it's going to be a huge
challenge Rachel Rollins actually talks
about it and she's like running for da
is like a pie eating contest and then
the prize if you win is more pie like
it's like the it's like it's not easy
it's certainly going to require a lot of
growing pains especially when the
leadership is going to be like kind of a
polar opposite from what the current
leadership is um so I do think that
there will certainly
be a a you know there'll be transitions
there'll be growing pains there'll be
difficulties but I do think that over
time you know when we think about
crafting new incentives within DA's
office for career advancement when we
think about retraining employees and you
know designating objectives to change
the culture of prosecutors offices um
you know instead of
just you know just keeping the status
quo and maintaining business as usual um
I think we should be yeah just reframing
how we think about things and I think
that really what we're seeing right now
in terms of like what we've seen with
the Nationwide protests across the
country with like people are having a
there's a real Reckoning in our country
with the way in which our you know our
our criminal punishment bureaucracy
operates there's there are like broad
calls for racial Justice there are
people who who are like wow maybe the
objective of Prosecutor's offices should
be to achieve Justice and not just to
rack up convictions so I do think that
like people are are kind of coming
around to position and that although
there's going to be there of course will
be challenges to to any change and of
course there will be people who are
resistant to change I think that there
are a lot of people who are like wow we
actually should think about different
ways that we measure success we should
do a better job engaging with victims
you know the funny thing that I that I
would see across the board is like you
know the da would be like oh my Victim
my Victim very protective of their
victims and yet my clients there there's
were today's today's you know person
being accused and tomorrow's victim like
there there's not really very much that
differentiates them and in fact the way
the system operates does so little to to
help victims we don't really think about
uh you know there's um a woman who
writes uh her name is Danielle Sid she
writes a book called until we reckon and
it's really about like restorative
justice and thinking about our criminal
criminal legal system in a different way
and she says that if you picture you're
walking down a hill with the you know
human version with the
anthropomorphization of the criminal
legal system in you and you're walking
down a hill and someone runs up behind
you and shoves you down and you tumble
down the hill and you're you're laying
at the ground at the base of the Hill
you're just like bloody and broken all
the criminal legal system can do for you
is Chase down the person who did that to
you and beat the [__] out of them
too and I think it's such a a good
demonstrative example because the person
who's laying there bleeding and bloody
and they're like hey can someone help me
and they're like we've got your back and
they're just gonna go beat someone else
up but but we don't think about really
healing victims and how we can address
helping them you know with with the
issues they're facing too and and so I
just think there are ways to like really
reframe these these thought processes
and I and I think and hope that that
people won't be as resistant to them
once they see how they can work last
thing I want to talk about is uh private
prisons I asked for questions on Twitter
um and I got a ton of questions but this
is by far the most popular question is
just like private prisons are bad uh I
know very very little about this uh you
I'm assuming know way more but I may be
incorrect uh talk about just kind of
private prisons and and what are the
issues there and kind of how do we solve
any problems you
see oh well it's so it's so interesting
because so many people talk about
private prisons they're like oh private
prisons private prisons are the problem
they're so terrible look at all these
people who are profiting off of um off
of prison oh this the the private prison
problem but the reality is it's they're
not the problem I mean listen should
private prisons be abolished absolutely
but they aren't the real problem and and
I think that like it's it's been like
loow hanging fruit in terms of in terms
of really thinking about these issues
that people are like oh we need to end
private prisons and it's like that
doesn't address the much larger issue of
mass incarceration and the prison
industrial complex you know I mean think
of the fact that most of the people who
are incarcerated are not incarcerated in
in private prisons but they are still
it's still a multi- I think
multi-billion I don't want to get that
wrong but I think it's a multi-billion
dollar industry and people who are
incarcerated are charged for every
little thing I mean if you think about
like securist being one of the worst uh
offenders like people who are who are
being charged the that's the phone
company yeah if you've ever listened to
a jail call I've listened to so many
hundreds of hours of jail calls but it's
like you have one minute in I mean they
charge people an exorbitant amount to
just keep in touch with their family
members and this isn't in private
prisons but it's still part of the
prison industrial complex and still part
of you know thinking about all the
people that we incarcerate and profit
off of I mean I think like one of the
big things that came out like during the
whole covid crisis was like um New York
State prisoners were being used to
produce hand
sanitizer and uh it was you know you
can't even possess hand sanitizer while
you're inis because it contains alcohol
so it's it's Contraband and yet they're
being used to to they're being profited
off of so it's just like one of the
things that that you know I think
private prisons Listen by emphasizing
private prisons people are are saying
like oh well non-private prisons are
okay and really like you know State and
federally owned prisons are downplayed
um or implicitly I guess seen as a more
ethical form of imprisonment but that's
just it's just not it's not true it's
like I think it's around 8% of our um of
our you know the massive number of
people that we incarcerate in this
country or in privately owned prisons um
but is it fair to say federal and state
owned prisons exploit prisoner labor
like as well yeah is it fair to say that
uh in a private prison there's a
corporation or you know private group of
individuals that are profiting but in a
non-private prison it's just the state
or federal government profiting like is
the business model the same uh and it's
just who's collecting the check kind of
thing or is it something different well
so even in state run facilities people
are still working for private Industries
and there are still private industries
that are profiting off of them even in
but like does the state like so take
like Riker's Island right which uh my
understanding is it's not a private
prison uh is there a revenue like is
there profit being d uh driven at Rikers
that then whether the local state or
federal government is taking in sure so
so they are often produc like you know
places that produce goods for example
it's for the benefit of government
agencies but even then their labor is
still hyp exploited to the benefit of
the agency's bottom lines like it's it's
really um you know even if the profit is
is like for the production of the actual
Goods is for the for the government
agency it's still really um you know
like the pro if the pro if the problem
is profit then institutions that are
unjustly benefiting from the labor of
people who are
incarcerated like the that means that
fighting private prisons is really only
the beginning got it that makes sense um
before I go into the kind of Rapid Fire
questions to uh to wrap this up uh
what's your like 30 second Pitch to
people like why can you do the job of
the district attorney better than anyone
else that potentially wants to do that
job um you know I mean I think that it's
really it what it really comes down to
is that I am someone who has worked as a
public defender for my entire career
I've represented over 3,000 people
charged with crimes I have gone up
against the Manhattan DA's office
against a criminal punishment
bureaucracy that's cruel unjust and I'm
the only public defender running I never
aspired to be a prosecutor I've never
worked as one but I I know that we can
do better I know what we need to change
and I know how to change it and after a
decade in the criminal courthouse I'm
ready to get in there to be Unapologetic
and fearless in making those changes and
you know making New York a fairer and
more just and safer place for everyone
as your next Manhattan District attorney
it's a pretty good pitch thanks uh I
asked the same two questions everybody
and then you'll get to ask me one to uh
trrap it up after I've badgered you with
questions for two hours uh the first one
is what's the most important book that
you've ever
read
o that's such a good
one oh man I don't I don't have like an
easy answer let me think for like one
minute
the most important book you can say a
couple if if you can't decide on just
one oh my gosh let me like look at my my
bookshelf oh
man what are the ones that are coming to
mind um you know I'm thinking about I'm
thinking about like both you know I'm
thinking about fiction and
non-fiction um because I think like I'm
someone who loves go I go back and forth
like I I try to read um I try to read
both um and let me see I'm looking
through my Kindle
now
um God I'm just trying to think so like
one of the like most heart-wrenching
best fiction books I've read recently
was called a little
life okay have you read it I have not oh
my God it's just I mean it's just like
absolutely
heart-wrenchingly devastating and it is
you know about about human beings and
about lives and you know you you see the
people in the in the novel and you kind
of
recognize that everyone
is dealing with their
own their own stuff their own struggles
and you never know from the outside
looking in because it goes from
different people's perspectives what
someone is facing
and it just I
think requires you to have like a great
deal of empathy when you when you think
about it when you read it and you you
really like dive into the to the
humanity in in different people and even
if from the outside looking in you think
oh this person's being whatever this
person's doing whatever and you judge
them based on their words or their
actions you know and then you it from
their perspective like that I think um I
don't know really it it really tugs the
heartstrings it's a book that I read
that like I have probably not stopped
thinking about since I read it wow
that's great suggestion um you had
another one I do I I think that in a
similar vein because I guess this this
all kind of ties in and the reason why I
think both of these books are so
important is probably because of of what
they do
for the for the reader and I think that
the other one I'll say is called um new
Jack guarding sing sing and it's it's a
non-fiction book about written by this
guy who's a journalist he's a reporter
and
he always wanted to report on our prison
system here in New York and every time
he was allowed to go into any part of
the prison they would like clear out
everyone who was there they would show
him this like sanitized PR they'd walk
him in they'd be like okay you're done
out you go and he never was able to
report on it he's like so I realized the
only way I would get to report on it is
by being on the inside so I could either
you know get arrested for a felony and
sentenced or I could become a a
correction officer and so he became a
correction officer at singing which is
one of our most notorious prisons in
Upstate New York um for a year and he
writes about well he intersperses you
know the history of the prison itself
with his experience as as a guard and
he'd gone through the entire training
and and you know took the correction
officer test and he you know the way he
writes about it is so is so important I
think because he says you know some of
the guards he he worked alongside were
were monsters they were sadists and they
were incredibly punitive and they were
really awful to to all the human beings
who are incarcerated there and and some
of them were just were decent people who
are just waking up every day and trying
to get a paycheck and trying to provide
for their family and a stable job and he
said some of the people who were
incarcerated were you know um really
really um dangerous potentially
dangerous people who' committed very
serious crimes and some were mentally
ill and he saw the way in which they
were impacted by solitary confinement or
other horrible uh ways in which we you
know punitively segregate people um and
some of them he had beautiful
relationships with like one guy who
loved to to read and write poetry and he
would bring him poetry books and the two
of them would sit and talk about poetry
and so like basically how he shows that
all human beings like there's no like
things aren't black and white and we
can't view people as we can't other
people and just say oh these people are
criminals these people
are and and therefore we can write them
all off and it just kind of humanizes
everyone in the process and I think like
does a really beautiful job of that so
those are the two books that come to
mind right now that's great suggestion
uh second question is more fun uh aliens
are you a Believer or a
non-believer
um I think there are probably other life
forms out there you know I I don't think
that I'm so closed-minded as to think
that we are we are it but I don't spend
much time thinking about aliens
admittedly so I have to ask you only
because it recently came up I I
personally believe that there's other
stuff out there who knows if we'll come
in contact with them uh but given that
you have a legal background uh and spend
all day thinking about the law uh
recently there were some people up in
arms because Elon Musk was asked about
hey if you actually get to Mars uh what
are you gonna do about the law and he
basically was like well we're gonna come
up with our own laws like of course like
we're the settlers and people were
freaking out and they were saying about
international law and you know kind of
you can imagine very quickly people
don't like the fact of Elon Musk coming
up with the laws of another
planet and so uh I now have spent way
too many hours thinking about like if
you could design uh a whole new planet
set of laws like what would you change I
won't I won't ask you to to say that but
uh it's fascinating to think about right
because literally uh I don't know if we
do it in his lifetime but like
somebody's gonna be the first person to
get to Mars and does that mean the
United States laws become law does that
mean there's new Mars laws I have no
clue but don't either that's something
that hadn't really crossed my mind until
you just brought it up so it'll
definitely be a a new a new place I
don't think it had cross a lot of
people's mind until Elon said something
about it and uh you know it's hard to
tell if he's serious or it's just a
marketing Ploy but uh but but uh he
definitely got people talking about it
so that was a good one um all right you
could ask me one question to uh finish
this up what uh what one question do you
have for
me oh my gosh um that's a tough question
too but let me think
[Music]
um all right I've got one all right it's
personal is that okay of course um when
was the last time you cried and why o
last time I cried that's a great
question
uh the last time I like fullon cried
like fullon
cried had to be when I was
young I was probably
like a
teenager trying to think like I have
memories of
crying but
like stupid stuff H like I don't know
like my I got mad at my parents and I
was like 15 or 14 you know like went in
my room and cried like a because like a
little baby um like I have that in terms
of like got te eyed uh my wife
appreciate this story which is uh we
were um the New York City
marathon uh comes down I think it's
second a or goes up second half uh and
um this is maybe two or three years ago
and we're standing out there you it's
just kind of a cool thing you see people
running by whatever and she tells me uh
oh did you ever hear the story about the
Texas dad and I was like there's a lot
of dads in Texas like what do you mean
and she goes no one year for I think it
was the Boston Marathon uh a guy who uh
was a pretty athletic Runner you know
obviously qualified for the Boston
Marathon was uh sitting at home and uh
before the marathon um his daughter said
uh Hey Dad we're gonna see you on TV
today and he said I promise you I'll uh
you'll see me on TV today and he's going
to the thing and he's basically like why
the hell am I promising my daughters who
are old enough to know that if they
don't see me on TV they're going to
basically yell at me uh he goes how the
hell am I G to guarantee that this
happens so he gets it in his mind that
the only way to uh get on television is
to lead the Boston Marathon and so he's
in the first cohort which basically
means uh you know there's all the like
hardcore professional marathoners and
they're kind of joined by people who are
fast but not quite as fast as them and
so the way that she's telling me the
story she's like this guy comes out of
the block and uh basically just full-on
Sprints as fast as he possibly can at a
pace that is impossible to keep up for
any real distance but he gets out in
front so he's on television and she's
telling me this and uh I don't know why
like we don't have kids what you know
like whatever we're standing outside and
she looks at me she goes are you crying
I was like n it's it's windy like I I
don't know like wind in my eye or
whatever and so like for whatever reason
I I literally can't like when you ask me
when I CED like I literally it's
probably like when I was a teenager like
I just am not super emotional you know
people pass away what what just not but
for whatever reason that one story I
remember thinking like that's pretty
cool and so my next question to her was
like well what happened to the guy she's
like Well he kind of struggled the rest
of the race because he was so tired yeah
of course and I cry the marathon I
always cry at the marathon I like see
people running I don't know makes me I
but I cry at everything so so if you
cried watching a marathon uh I'll tell
you one more story Before I Let You Go
which is uh we went um I'm not a runner
but uh my my girlfriend at the time he
was my wife says uh hey we should go do
a marathon and I'm like I'm good like I
she you know she talking about the New
York City man I was like I've seen
Manhattan I don't need to like run
around like I just you know whatever and
she's like okay comes back to me a
couple weeks later she's like I have a
great idea why don't we go run the
original marathon in Greece cool and I
was like okay like that's interesting uh
and you know in hindsight she was
playing on my egotistical uh desire to
want every time somebody told me oh I
ran a marathon meay op she didn't run
the original so it doesn't count right
uh and so we go uh fly away to grees
we're running the marathon and uh all of
a sudden I look over and she's crying
while we're running she's crying I cried
I I ran a marathon I cried I fully cried
why did you cry because it was just hard
and painful and stuff no I they were
they were Joy tier it was like something
there was something like really special
about finishing a marathon I'm like like
I like have this huge smile and I'm
crying so you did it because you
finished the marathon and it was
exciting and all this stuff she was
crying because she saw somebody run up
to an old lady and give them a hug and I
was like how you were not focused on
running and like I'm like suffering I'm
like walking at every water station I'm
like this sucks I have not enjoyed a
single second of this whatsoever and
she's like running around you know just
looking I was like we are living in two
different worlds right now so and I had
my name on my on my shirt and like
people would be like go Eliza and i' be
like Oh my like it's like yeah you and
my wife would be like sister
like I feel like she would get me
absolutely all right where can we send
people to find you on the internet uh
find out more about the campaign and uh
learn more about uh just Criminal
Justice Reform in general where do you
want to send them uh they can check our
website out at Eliza orleans.com that's
El Za o r l i ns.com I'm Eliza orans on
Twitter e orans on Instagram um very
active on social media so people can my
DMs are open you know any questions
happy to happy to field them
awesome well listen thank you so much
you've been incredibly gracious with
your time I think we're going on two
hours here so uh hopefully people
learned a ton from this uh it goes
without saying that uh we need to change
a lot of things um and hopefully this
just highlighted some of those issues
for people but we'll have to do it again
in the future this was so much fun
thanks for having me